[Music]
he has to feel free in German
by
you can go to a country to learn a
language like language courses
condemn housing we give
pocket money it's all good
to deliver cities and  pelé makes
pauline flour and rai 3 a clause in the
event of ingrid of the boys
you that the sheep in retirement and couiza
must it is the tactical aspect the
files to the public and the piano and cries
for trita garden solidarity with the offers
there were twenty meters with closer more
line to zoubair ben sport de beauf
the emigrant from gaza
an order
[Music]
good moment favorite it's writing that
's 100% sure we're trying to create the
little spark for  precisely we
reach as many people as possible and in addition
try to make people think about
these subjects which are not so
important and which we have the impression that
they do not reach because it may
be less of us when in the end
it  it has to be happy everywhere every
time and that we think about it  all and
that we see what we can all do
together in fact
michael de manioc times president of
[ __ ] who limits the breakage what do it is
why device
dad we need to have in and inclusive
society there is only one  pair race of the
quinté sees the possibility of
long periods in different cakes
and queer x show as a
formative review admitted the film does the peña
win tom that she embodies the
African Christmas I believe that what I
learned and that  we can learn that
traveling in 11 years we hope like
this it's open-mindedness and
I want to invest myself more in the
things I want to defend
sexy size studios in chur
m